Traduttore: Maria Pia Lanfranchi
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Vi svelo un segreto:
la vela è uno sport a cui si può
avvicinare chiunque, a qualunque età.
Infatti tra i velisti ci sono sia bambini
che veleggiano di fronte alla spiaggia,
come ultrasettantenni che girano il mondo
sul loro guscio galleggiante.
Ma anche dei giovani e adulti,
diversamente abili,
che solcano i mari in piena sicurezza.
Se poi, appena appena,
ti prende la passione,
nelle ore di navigazione,
con le splendide emozioni,
quasi neanche ti rendi più conto
di quanto tutte le piccole
semplici lezioni che hai imparato
formino un affresco
di un'affascinante complessità.
Infatti, la vela agonistica,
tra gli sport, se non il più complesso,
sicuramente è uno dei più complessi.
Molteplici sono i fattori
di cui tenere conto:
ovviamente, la preparazione
mentale e fisica
ma soprattutto un continuo perfezionamento
della tecnica di conduzione della barca.
Poi ci sono da saper interpretare
le previsioni metereologiche,
e queste servono a poter impostare
la strategia di regata e la tattica.
Ma non si può trascurare
la preparazione della barca,
con l'ottimizzazione
di vele, scafo e appendici.
Per dare un'idea della complessità,
prendiamo per esempio Rio de Janeiro,
dove si svolgeranno
le prossime olimpiadi ad agosto.
Un atleta si troverà a navigare
su uno dei sette campi di regata
e, durante le otto ore al giorno
in cui è possibile svolgere le regate,
può incontrare uno dei cinque
differenti scenari meteo.
Quindi, per non farsi mancare nulla,
c'è anche la corrente che,
con una periodicità di dodici ore,
varia ogni ora.
Questo significa che
un atleta e il suo allenatore
devono saper dare la giusta priorità
a circa 3.000 differenti scenari,
dando per scontato che a livello
tecnico e mentale sia tutto perfetto.
Ora,
grazie ai miei studi in fisica,
il mio profilo professionale,
tra le persone che fanno
l'allenatore in questo sport,
è raro,
quindi ho avuto la possibilità
di ideare delle soluzioni, dei metodi,
offrire una fonte
di informazione oggettiva
dove prima c'erano dubbi,
oppure opinioni
o, in generale, assenza di informazione.
Ma non sarei arrivato a raggiungere
nessuno di questi obiettivi
se non ci fosse stata
una grande passione
che mi spingesse a trovare ogni volta
nuove domande e relative risposte.
Vediamo alcuni esempi.
Per un atleta e il suo allenatore,
avere il massimo numero di informazioni
per i campi di regata in cui
si svolgono le regate più importanti
è fondamentale e, per alcuni
di questi campi di regata,
la corrente dovuta alla marea
è un fattore prioritario
dal punto di vista strategico.
Ma non per tutte queste località
è disponibile un atlante
che descriva come la corrente
dovuta alla marea si comporta.
Da qui il problema:
come fare a misurare la corrente
in maniera semplice, ma accurata?
E, una volta raccolti i dati,
è possibile creare delle mappe,
delle cartine, che la descrivano?
Così, lavorando nell'ambito
della ricerca e sviluppo
per Swiss Sailing Team,
ho avuto modo di sviluppare
un metodo, un progetto,
che si avvale di un algoritmo
detto Streamviewer, da noi creato,
grazie al quale,
tramite una raccolta di dati
con uno strumento da noi ideato,
siamo in grado di elaborare delle cartine
che descrivano come si comporta
la corrente dovuta alla marea,
per qualsivoglia località
e offrire questa fonte di informazione
agli atleti che competono
per la nostra squadra.
Ma non è solo questo uno
dei campi di cui mi sono occupato.
Anche la metodologia
dell'allenamento, legata alla vela,
è stato un altro grande tema.
Infatti, come probabilmente
è possibile immaginare,
le condizioni meteo marine,
con cui ci si allena,
influenzano fortemente l'allenamento.
Dunque, se da un lato è facile
o possibile pianificare l'allenamento
e gli obiettivi che
si intende raggiungere,
ben più difficile è riuscire a valutare
se effettivamente sono stati raggiunti.
Dunque,
da qui nasce la necessità
di voler creare uno strumento
che aiuti l'allenatore a monitorare,
a vedere, a visualizzare
lo scollamento tra l'attività pianificata
e quella realmente svolta.
Quindi, applicando una standardizzazione
ai dati raccolti tramite planning report,
è nato Team Data Log che poi,
nel tempo, è diventato una piattaforma
multidisciplina e multiutente,
volta all'incremento della performance
attraverso l'analisi dello sport,
l'analisi delle discipline
con finalità predittive e storiche.
Di fatto, è uno strumento
che offre all'allenatore
la possibilità di visualizzare
su quali obiettivi intendeva lavorare,
in confronto a quali sono
gli obiettivi che ha raggiunto,
in relazione a quelle che sono
le condizioni metereologiche.
Ora, sono 20 anni
che o partecipo a regate,
o le seguo come allenatore.
Dunque,
cercare di raggiungere obiettivi,
risolvere problemi
è diventata più un'attitudine
che un lavoro.
E così ho iniziato a chiedermi
quali fossero gli elementi
che guidano da un problema
alla sua soluzione,
qual è lo spazio che sta tra
il desiderio di raggiungere l'obiettivo
e il suo raggiungimento.
E così ho tracciato un percorso,
basandomi sulle esperienze
raccolte in questi anni,
e immaginate adesso di essere un atleta,
all'inizio della propria carriera:
c'è bisogno di imparare metodi, tecniche,
movimenti estremamente complessi,
se davvero volete raggiungere
il vostro obiettivo.
E quindi, come fare?
Suddividete i vostri gesti complessi
in gesti più semplici,
quindi quando devo
affrontare un problema,
qualunque sia il grado di complessità,
lo approccio suddividendolo
in piccole parti,
in maniera che ciascuno
dei sottoproblemi, dei sottoinsiemi,
sia più facilmente risolvibile,
sia più facilmente
raggiungibile la soluzione.
Alcuni saranno complessi,
si commetteranno sicuramente errori,
anche l'atleta li commette e si corregge,
ma i problemi da affrontare
sono più semplici.
Una volta affrontato questo primo step,
allora ci si può avviare
verso una prima visione d'insieme,
verso un primo ricongiungimento
dei movimenti base:
l'atleta inizia a fare
movimenti più complessi
e inizia a non occuparsi più
della tecnica, soltanto della tecnica,
ma anche della tattica e della strategia,
quindi inizia ad avere
una visione d'insieme,
così noi iniziamo a tracciare
una visione di insieme
verso la soluzione
che vogliamo raggiungere.
E allora, a questo punto,
arriva il momento di confrontarsi.
Arriva il momento di aprirsi
a un gruppo di riferimento.
Arriva il momento di avere
una proattiva contaminazione
con le persone e avere uno scambio,
perché se da soli siamo stati in grado
di entrare nel dettaglio del problema
e poi uscire e avere
una visione di insieme,
adesso grazie al confronto
con altre persone
possiamo spostarci
su diversi sistemi di riferimento
e vedere il problema
in tutta la sua interezza.
Così, l'atleta, quando va in competizione,
grazie al confronto con gli avversari,
può sapere quanto gli manca
per raggiungere l'obiettivo.
E dunque, può colmare
questo gap rimanente
per cercare di ottenere il suo obiettivo.
Quindi, successivamente,
siamo in grado di convergere
verso la soluzione del nostro problema;
siamo in grado di sapere quanto manca
e siamo in grado di -
con ovviamente
un grandissimo sforzo finale,
perché è là dove il lavoro certosino -
dove serve ancora che la passione spinga
per riuscire a raggiungere l'obiettivo,
ma sappiamo che cosa manca per farlo.
A questo punto, come l'atleta
potrà essere vincente,
se riesce a raggiungere
il suo obiettivo, la sua medaglia,
saremo sicuramente molto soddisfatti
di quello che abbiamo ottenuto.
Ma potrebbe anche succedere
e bisogna tenerne conto,
che noi non riusciremo
a essere i più bravi,
o a essere i primi
a raggiungere l'obiettivo,
e sarà bruciante
come una medaglia sfiorata.
Ma la soddisfazione deriva
soltanto dal successo alla fine?
La soddisfazione deriva,
in gran parte, dal percorso che si fa
verso l'obiettivo:
è tutto il bagaglio che
si raccoglie lungo l'esperienza,
ed è un bagaglio che nessuno
potrà mai toglierci,
ed è il bagaglio che ci da la forza per
ricominciare ogni volta una nuova sfida.
Perché se è un'inesauribile passione
che ci spinge verso il nuovo obiettivo,
ed è una sana spinta competitiva
che ci chiede di arrivarci per primi,
è il metodo che applichiamo per farlo
che ci permette di farlo bene,
magari anche meglio degli altri.
Grazie.
(Applausi)